So, the process from an MVP to
getting funded is really depending on
many factors, perhaps the main
one being the domain you're at.
So there some domains, like security for
example, that may be an MVP,
plus an early pilot would be
enough to get seed funding.
There some domains,
perhaps a mobile application,
that more often than not requires
more than just a basic MVP, but
actually some proof in the market that
this can be something interesting.
Clearly, there's no rules,
and no right or wrong, but
it really does depend on the domain
you're at, but once you're ready,
it's about having everything
you need in order to fundraise.
You need to show that you have
some plan of what you want to
do with the market or what you want to
do with the money when you fundraise.
You have the team, and
the MVP is a good indicator that,
you know what, maybe it's
interesting what you've built.
And this MVP shows not only your
ability as a team to execute, but
the market is receptive
to what you have built.